[Music]
on this Tuesday night one step closer to
a fusion-powered future the excitement
over a potential new source of clean
energy one of the most impressive
scientific Feats of the 21st century how
does it work and how soon could it be
powering our world
a plan for cultural reform a Canada's
military we are here with a road map for
Progress what the defense minister laid
out and why the military is accused of
foot dragging the Empire of fraud
charges against a former crypto mobile
and founder of FTX this is one of the
biggest Financial frauds in American
history plus the Revolutionary treatment
that made this teenager cancer-free
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with what scientists claim is a
breakthrough which sets the course for a
future of near Limitless clean energy
after Decades of research and billions
of dollars invested American researchers
say their nuclear fusion experiments
combining two particles into One
released more energy than was pumped in
by the lab's enormous high-powered
lasers a landmark achievement known as
ignition or energy gain
last week at the Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory in California
scientists at the national ignition
facility achieved Fusion ignition
and that is creating more energy from
Fusion reactions than the energy used to
start the process
the technology is far from being ready
to turn into viable power plants and
it's not about to solve the climate
crisis but it is a huge step forward in
harnessing the power of the Stars here
on Earth Eric Sorensen has our top story
tonight
this is one of the lasers that Zapped an
historic breakthrough for science after
Decades of research Fusion in a
laboratory the same process that powers
the sun signals vast new possibilities
to produce energy without radiation or
carbon emissions it could one day power
everything from batteries to entire
cities many said it was not possible
it's only the beginning but this is a
good day for science the Science and
Technology challenges on the path to
Fusion Energy are daunting but making
the seemingly impossible possible is
when we're at our very best we've come
to understand fission the power and the
hazards from splitting uranium atoms
fusing hydrogen atoms the simplest most
common element in the universe releases
far more far cleaner energy but look
what it took to do so at the Lawrence
Livermore laboratory in California
inside the length of three football
fields 192 laser beams blasting split
seconds of energy creating tens of
millions of degrees focused into a tiny
cylinder under pressurizing a capsule
smaller than a BB creating a controlled
sustained burst of Fusion Energy for the
first time the Fusion fuel stayed hot
enough for long enough
that it ignited and it produced more
energies than the lasers had deposited
that's the Breakthrough getting more
energy out of the reaction than all of
the energy that went into it and that
would make Fusion Energy possible
scientists are almost giddy if we had
Fusion we could drop fossil fuels
immediately and forever just remember
fusion power has no nuclear waste to
speak of no meltdowns to worry about but
technology could enhance National
Security for America's nuclear weapons
program but the greater goal for many is
Limitless clean energy the possibility
of zero carbon abundant Fusion Energy
powering our society Canada's General
Fusion based in Vancouver has spent
years developing a different type of
fusion system with Partners in the UK
that could see a commercial Fusion plant
operating in the next decade and while
it is a highly competitive field Greg
twinney is thrilled with the news from
California this is massive massive of
validation for the industry a huge
science achievement and really what it
does is it demonstrates to the world
that Fusion is not science fiction much
of the world's modern unnecessary energy
has been developed with risks to human
health and at the expense of the
environment Fusion could be the energy
of the future that does no harm Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
Canada's defense minister has set out
what she calls an ambitious roadmap for
cultural change in the armed forces
Anita anands says her goal is to put in
place institutional reforms that will
endure and end the long history of
sexual harassment and misconduct the
Need For Change was set out in a
blistering report by retired Supreme
Court Justice Louise Arbor earlier this
year our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson is with me Mercedes what did
the defense minister say
well Donna they waited basically to the
last minute with their deadline here in
terms of accepting recommendations but
they do say as you mentioned they accept
all recommendations it was interesting
today that we saw the minister was much
more emotional than we typically see her
talking about her dedication to Bringing
change to the forces which have been
struggling with low morale and
difficulty recruiting
it will take time and we will see it
through
and finally I will say that as Minister
we never know how long we are going to
hold our positions but my goal is to put
in place the institutional reforms
necessary so that cultural change can
last our lifetime what is it
so there's two really big announcements
here Donna the first is that the
minister has ordered the military to
hand all sexual crimes over to civilian
authorities but that's already proving a
bit thorny because civilian authorities
have only accepted 57 cases and rejected
another 40. they too have limitations
with resources the second big one is
that they are going to review the Royal
Military College of Canada and Royal
Military College St John those were seen
as Untouchable in military culture they
shape how our Future Leaders think but
they're also a bit of a problem
according to a lot of experts when it
comes to sexualized culture in the
military and inner report in May
Mercedes Louise our board described the
military as a deeply deficient Culture
fostered by a rigid and outdated
structure what did she say today
well she's not impressed with the
progress either the military or the
government has made she says senior
leaders are foot dragging and that the
minister is just ordering more and more
reviews without specifics and focusing
internally when she recommended external
action
I find that all the reviews that are
being suggested in The Minister's
response are for the most part internal
and therefore misses entirely the
central point of my report which is the
need for kef to open up to a lot more
external not only scrutiny but input
everyone understands that change takes
time but experts are saying that there
has to be a clear road map of who what
when and why for people to take this
change seriously Donna all right
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
new details have emerged about alleged
Chinese interference in Canada's 2019
federal election a national security
Memo from February of 2020 was presented
today at a parliamentary Committee in
Ottawa it reveals key information about
an alleged foreign interference network
with links to China Mackenzie gray has
the details
Donna new documents obtained by global
news show the government knew about
investigations into alleged Chinese
interference in the 2019 election years
before we previously knew in an
intelligence assessment Memo from
February 2020 the privy Council Office
says there is a subtle but effective
intelligence networks being run by China
investigations into activities linked to
the Canadian federal election in 2019
reveal an active foreign interference
Network the minister responsible for
Democratic institutions says he hasn't
seen the document but did admit to being
briefed on Election issues our ability
to discuss publicly the details of those
national security briefings is
understandably limited that was true of
predecessor governments as first
reported by global news sources say that
in January of this year Canadian
intelligence officials delivered a
series of sensitive briefings to warn
the Prime Minister and select members of
his cabinet that ceases had evidence
that China ran a sophisticated operation
intended to influence the 2019 vote the
alleged plan to funnel a quarter million
dollars to 11 different candidates
liberals and conservatives I never got
briefings on candidates receiving money
from China and that so that's something
that we know
getting further into details we know
there is ongoing interference in Canada
we're going to continue to try and
counter it Global News has not reported
C says brief tutor on specific
identities of candidates who received
nearly a quarter million dollars in
donations foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie also saying she had no
information about the alleged
interference and I can confirm you that
I have no information
regarding this particular issue the same
documents from the privy Council show a
national security Outlook from before
the 2019 vote which shows the government
believed the election would be an
attractive Target for foreign States and
describe foreign interference as the
most significant threat to Canada's
long-term Prosperity Donna okay
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks the
federal liberals have easily won a
by-election in a riding in Greater
Toronto it was the first Federal
by-election since Pierre paliev became
conservative leader in an area of the
country crucial to his party's chances
of success in future Federal elections
former Ontario Finance Minister Charles
Sousa held the Mississippi a Lakeshore
seat for the Liberals Susa increased the
margin of victory over the conservatives
by nine points compared to the 2021
federal election something that's not a
win for the Liberals the ethics
commissioner has determined the
international trade Minister broke
parliamentary ethics rules Mary Eng
violated the federal conflict of
interest act when she awarded two
government contracts to a close friend
David Aiken explains what she did and
her response
the two contracts went to a public
relations firm called Pomp and
Circumstance an agency that is
co-founded and run by Amanda olvero a
friend of 20 years and one-time
spokesperson for international trade
Minister Mary Eng one contract was
awarded in 2020 and another in 2019 both
were for media training helping Minister
ing deal with reporters in scrums and in
interviews both contracts were awarded
without competition or public tender
they had a combined value of about
twenty three thousand dollars the ethics
commissioner concluded a minister cannot
play any role in the decision to award
government contracts to friends or
family and as a report indicates I take
full responsibility for my actions I
should have recused myself and I
apologize for not doing so and that was
good enough for her boss we thank the
ethics commissioner for his hard work
and the minister spoke directly to that
and has
apologized in a statement but not good
enough for her opponents who say this
continues a pattern of Ethics violations
by liberal cabin ministers the Prime
Minister himself has broken the act on
two separate occasions we've got
ministers found guilty of breaking acts
of parliament-breaking laws passed by
this place and and so we'll be looking
for looking for missing to appear today
and uh and to offer her resignation at
the very least conservatives want Inc to
pay back the tax dollars that went to
her friend's firm here will this
Minister be held accountable and will
she be required to pay back the twenty
three thousand dollars in improper
Contracting that she gave out and yet
there are no penalties for violating the
conflict of interest act no fines
Minister ing will keep her job if there
was any sanction it was the brief
political headache she caused her
government in the House of Commons today
Donna okay David Aiken in Ottawa thank
you for multi-billion dollar crypto
Mogul to jail in the Bahamas coming up
the man accused of one of the biggest
Financial frauds in American history
plus the paralyzing snowstorm barreling
towards Canada
New York prosecutors say he may not fit
the typical profile of someone who
cheats investors but they are accusing
Sam bankman freed of one of the biggest
Financial frauds in American history
bankman freed convinced investors
including celebrities to Back Him
building a multi-billion Dollar
cryptocurrency Empire he was arrested in
the Bahamas on Monday and as Jackson
prosco reports prosecutors now allege he
had a long-running scheme to do fraud
people in order to enrich himself
alleging he built a massive Empire of
fraud prosecutors say sam bankman freed
used his FTX crypto exchange to lure in
investors and embezzle their money
before it all came crashing down he used
that money for his personal benefit
including to make personal Investments
and to cover expenses and debts
prosecutors filed eight counts against
the one-time crypto King including wire
fraud Securities fraud and conspiracy to
commit money laundering they say the
money financed Alameda research his
risky hedge fund and was used to buy
lavish properties in the Bahamas where
bankman freed was arrested Monday there
were also nearly 40 million dollars in
political contributions to both parties
all of this dirty money was used in
service of bankman Freed's desire to buy
bipartisan influence and impact the
direction of public policy in Washington
one big snake in a crypto Garden of Eden
at a hearing into ft ex where bankman
freed was originally set to testify the
new CEO warned investors may never
recover their losses this is really
old-fashioned embezzlement this is just
taking money from customers and using it
for your own purpose not sophisticated
at all with trading crypto FTX is the
safest and easiest way to buy and sell
crypto from Super Bowl ads to celebrity
investors and a one-time valuation of 32
billion dollars FTX unraveled after
crypto prices collapsed when investors
started pulling their money on mass they
discovered FTX couldn't pay bankman
freed has blamed sloppy accounting I
feel really really bad and regretful
that I wasn't and a lot of people got
hurt and that that's on me prosecutors
now say it was no accident rather a
Brazen scheme that cost thousands of
investors their life savings and topple
the digital currency Empire Jackson
prosco Global News wash Washington
walking off the job ahead why a rail
strike is just the start of Labor
disruptions in the UK
[Music]
[Music]
a massive winter storm is sweeping
across the U.S it stretches across
thousands of kilometers covers more than
a dozen states winter storm alerts are
in effect for more than 15 million
people thousands of flights are canceled
or delayed many roads closed and there
are warnings of freezing rain flash
floods and even tornadoes the storm is
expected to spill into western Canada
heavy snow and high winds are forecast
across the prairies
people in the UK are dealing with some
Canadian style winter weather this week
snow and ice warnings are in place
across the UK hundreds of flights have
been canceled roads are amassed trains
are delayed Scotland recorded a record
low of -17 the weather combined with
another National Rail strike is making
commuting a challenge and it starts just
rail workers walking off the job from
Health Care to mail delivery for many
Brits this is the season of strikes
Redmond Shannon explains why
London's major train stations are
normally Mayhem but for most of this
week they're only operating a skeleton
service we want to get home we don't
know how when the trains aren't working
rail staff are on strike again demanding
wages catch up with high inflation many
people of course that are traveling are
also suffering similar things that their
health workers postal workers people
working in all sorts of Industries but
it's not just rail workers who are
walking off the job tens of thousands of
people in the UK's public and private
sectors are striking a level of
industrial action not seen here for
three decades in the coming days up to
100
000 nurses will strike followed by
ambulance workers and as Christmas
approaches staff at Royal Mail plan to
walk off the job as will airport ground
staff and members of the UK's border
Force London bus driver Nick Warner
thinks brexit was a mistake but it is
part of the reason work workers feel
empowered to strike we can say we we
want 10 and we get it
because they can't just there's there
isn't a cheap labor queuing up outside
bus garages
for jobs according to one Economist a
decade of public sector austerity is the
reason the UK is struck by strikes
nurses in particular
um haven't just seen their pay fall
behind over the last 10 years but
they're also facing uh these really big
workload pressures in the aftermath of
the pandemic in fact more nurses are
reportedly turning to food banks their
Union asking for a 19 raise and I think
most people watching will will recognize
that that's obviously unaffordable but
unless deals get struck Britain could be
in for a miserable winter of walkouts
Redmond Shannon Global News London
as high inflation plays a role in the UK
in labor unrest there are signs
inflation is easing in the United States
new numbers out today show a slight rise
but the smallest annual increase in a
year consumer Prices rose 7.1 percent in
November that's down from 7.7 percent in
October and June's peak of 9.1 percent
marking the fifth straight slowdown in
prices in the U.S
medical miracle next to revolutionary
treatment for a teenager with cancer
in the UK a teenager with an aggressive
form of leukemia is now cancer free
thanks to an experimental therapy her
blood cancer didn't respond to
Conventional treatment so doctors use
Gene editing technology to Target the
disease and the result was life-changing
Mike droulet reports on how it works and
the possibilities it offers
Alyssa was only 12 years old when she
was diagnosed with a form of leukemia
that's 96 percent curable she soon found
out she was in the other four percent
chemotherapy didn't work leaving doctors
to suggest a revolutionary new treatment
called base editing six months later
Alyssa is cancer-free actually
because I have had new cells put into me
Gene editing is Cutting Edge doctors
modify the DNA in cells taken from the
patient so that they kill off cancer
cells however Alyssa's system proved
immune to the therapy so they used an
even newer technique called base editing
where they use donor T cells adopting
their DNA to make them invisible to
other cancer treatments as well as other
T cells allowing them to focus on the
cancer
it is a very exciting time for genetic
therapies
um we are finding every day there is a
new treatment coming up and which is
going to be more and more targeted the
particular therapy used on Alyssa was
only invented six years ago Dr Jack deep
Walia a Canadian researcher on the front
lines of gene therapy remembers the
concept as theoretical when he was in
medical school there's hope uh and more
and more hope is coming yes with newer
Technologies not only for leukemias or
cancers but also for many genetic
conditions where there was no treatment
before and now many new treatments are
coming but another way it's
revolutionizing the way doctors approach
disease Alyssa just happens to be the
first
I'm very honored
[Music]
um and it feels good to have helped
other people as well she'll be closely
monitored of course but this teenager's
life going forward looks normal
microlight Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is the tree of Hope in Kelowna BC
we'd love to see your festive Canada
photos please email them to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]